thank you
thank you very much Cara Georgia
distinguished guests
presidents Prime Ministers excellencies
ladies and Gentlemen We Gather here in
Rome with one shared objective
we're all facing many challenges but we
want
and we can turn our challenges into
opportunities
we can do this by building strong and
Lasting Partnerships
we all belong to one common region
we are connected by the Mediterranean
and we are connected by the ties of
history of travel and of trade
by cooperation
between north and south east and west of
the Mediterranean we see that this has
not always been the norm
we want to change this and that is the
reason why we gather here today
of course we are meeting in very special
times
we're all facing the dramatic reality of
climate change
we all need to switch to clean energy
and new farming techniques we all need
to train our Workforce for the jobs of
tomorrow
of course climate change is a challenge
but it is also and it Bears also huge
opportunities
and at the same time we have to stop the
exploitation of human suffering by
criminal Networks
we have to prevent the tragic loss of
life in the Mediterranean Sea
all these factors require a new way of
thinking
and they're required to develop new
strategic and comprehensive Partnerships
across the shores of the Mediterranean
a new strategic partnership for economic
and human development
for trade investment and migration
management
based on solidarity
sovereignty
and shared responsibilities
the mutual advantages are clear
just think about climate and the clean
energy transition
in Europe as we have ended our
dependency on Russian fossil fuels we
are massively investing in clean energy
to power our industries of tomorrow
we will produce clean energy in Europe
but we will also need to import quite
huge amounts of clean energy from abroad
producing clean energy and clean
electricity in the European Union costs
10 cent per kilowatt hour at best
Indonesia
it could cost as little as two cents
Tunisia has the necessary natural
resources of wind and sun in abundance
it would have a huge competitive
advantage
and this is a classical win-win
situation
Europe has an interest to invest in
Tunisia
and Tunisia has an interest to develop
capacities for home consumption and
export
but there's more
we will also work with Tunisia to
address the impacts of climate change
focusing on Water Management
and sustainable agriculture
this is essential to adapt to a drier
climate
distinguished guests
we want our agreement with Tunisia to be
a template
to Ability a blueprint for the future
for Partnerships with other countries in
the region
we want to take a pragmatic approach
based on shared values
and shared interests
we want to find solutions that are
tailored to the local realities
the first potential field for
cooperation is investment especially in
clean energy
this Mediterranean region has vast
natural resources like sun wind and
immense landscapes in abundance
you have the potential and the ambition
to be Global energy powerhouses in a net
zero world
Europe is already supporting this
ambition we have for example our
hydrogen Partnerships with Egypt and
Morocco
or on the broader scale
we have our global gateway investment
plan worth 300 billion euros
global gateway has not only the size to
make a difference
but it lays out a new approach to Big
infrastructure projects
European investment will come with a
very strong focus on creating local
value chains
global gateway is open to cooperation
with business with financial
institutions with public and private
investors
we do not only want to build clean
energy infrastructure
we also want to build Bridges between
the two shores of the Mediterranean
and this leads me to the second new
opportunity for cooperation
it is about people
and their perspective
it is about training the workforce that
new and emerging economies need
we can build a more balanced system
in which people move learn work
it is with this in mind that we have
developed the talent Partnerships
these Talent Partnerships aim precisely
at developing new skills
and creating new work and training
opportunities especially for young
people
these young people want to live their
dreams
and far too many of them
put their lives in the hands of Ruthless
Smugglers and traffickers
this has become a lucrative business
model of organized crime
but the reality is that criminals can
never guarantee a new start they trade
on dreams and human life
we must break this cynical business
model
opening new legal pathways
between our continents
can create a real and safe alternative
to the dangerous Journeys across the sea
and this is why at the European level
we are working to promote resettlement
and humanitarian admission
and at the same time we must crack down
on Smugglers and traffickers
we need to join forces
to dismantle the cruel and illegal
business model of criminals
and we need to work together on raising
people's awareness of the lies Smugglers
are spreading
distinguished guests
we are ready to work with you
we are ready
to set up operational Arrangements
that strengthen cooperation
between our law enforcement and judicial
authorities
together we can cooperate on search and
rescue and strengthening border
management
together we can and should manage
migration better
by guaranteeing protection to those in
need
be it in countries of transit or
destination
taking a root based approach
and by cooperating on the return of
those who do not have a right to stay
and supporting
their reintegration back home
and for that we can rely on the
invaluable support and expertise of
international organizations and European
agencies
distinguished guests dear fellow leaders
the wrong process is an opportunity to
team up
it is a new forum
to better understand one another
to identify each other's interests and
needs
and to find mutually beneficial
Solutions thank you very much
[Applause]